one of the biggest changes made to the
Star Wars Universe was the introduction
of Ahsoka Tano in the Clone Wars
although she doesn't appear in any of
the prequel movies Lucas and filoni did
a wonderful job interweaving the
character's narrative into the overall
universe of the prequels over time
Ahsoka would become one of the most
beloved characters in the entire Star
Wars Canon her popularity directly
leading to appearances and other shows
including her own spin-off series on
Disney plus aside from her frequent
appearances following the Clone Wars
Ahsoka also allowed a more layered
exploration of Anakin's character
gradually learning to become a more
mature Master to Ahsoka Anakin was
finally able to realize the burden of
having a pupil study under him the Jedi
orders poor treatment of Ahsoka also
provided an additional reason for his
frustrations with the Jedi in Revenge of
the Sith helping shed more light on his
turn to the dark side